all right we're talking about baseball
and first pitches because the double a
pensacola blue wahoos
are letting fans stay the night at the
stadium
if you rent it out via airbnb fifteen
hundred dollars a night you get access
to the newly renovated clubhouse batting
cajun field bats balls and helmets
provided bedroom with 10 beds that's not
a bad deal for 150 yeah
if it sleeps 10 you get a bunch of
buddies you get a couple of families
together you get a kid you know a few
kids i mean that that's that's not a bad
deal
uh for anybody in the pensacola area
fifteen hundred dollars a night
you get you can sleep ten and you can
just play baseball all night long so
right so the basis for today's draft nfl
stadiums you would rent for a vacation
chris uh this one's gonna be fun i've
got the trivia question for you and the
trivia question is which is the oldest
stadium
in the nfl
wow just coming out with the old what is
the oldest stadium in the nfl um
well i i would have to think that's
lambeau field no
no it's not it is soldier field opened
in 1924 lambeau field opened in 1957 the
third oldest stadium now that the
coliseum in oakland has been vacated by
the raiders arrowhead 1972. so soldier
field the oldest i get the first pick
and uh man
um
i i i have to start with one of the two
new ones um
and i'll i'll go i i'll go raiders
stadium allegiant stadium is the name of
it i just think it looks
cooler you talked earlier about how both
the new stadiums the la and the las
vegas stadiums look like they're ready
to take off and fly away into outer
space but you got to throw the vegas
factor into it as well i mean if you're
going to be there all week there's only
so much you can do in the football
stadium you're in las vegas for crying
out loud so between las vegas and los
angeles i'll take las vegas walk over to
the casino go see a show go to the
buffet come back to the stadium sleep it
off do it all over the next day i mean
they always talk about how great the
suites are in las vegas this is the
ultimate las vegas suite the entire
allegiance stadium so uh that's the one
that i would want without question well
i mean i i it looks cool it looks
amazing but i mean for the spirit of
this draft don't we want to stay in the
stadium and enjoy the stadium i mean
you're going to leave it you're going to
pay all that big money
you're going to save the whole week who
said nothing in this thing said a whole
week did it it just said rent for a
vacation that could be too nice i mean
you take a two-night vacation are you
that cheap
so well sometimes sometimes you just
gotta get away from the kids for like 24
vacations whatever it is that's a
weekend that's a getaway you don't have
a vacation you don't vacation kids you
forgot
vacation is at least a week all right uh
go ahead what's yours
is there going to be some slot machines
in vegas i mean yeah you're just renting
out a place and they're going to walk
out i don't get it see that's how i know
you're rich you're just going to rent it
out and go i don't need to stay here let
me go somewhere else um i'm planning on
hanging out in my place of vacation spot
so i mean i need sun
and i need a pool and
i don't care that it's not one of the
high-tech stadiums and all the football
i'm going to jacksonville baby that's
where i'm going at least i know i can be
outside in the sun if i do bring the
kids i can throw them around in the pool
do all those type of things be out there
during that
that to me i mean you can't have a
vacation without a pool and some sun so
that was an easy choice i mean i'm not
in love with that stadium but i would
like to swim in that pool at some point
yeah i've seen enough images of that
pool packed with people they would have
to empty it and scrub it like bill
murray and caddy shack in a hazmat suit
before i would do it there are benefits
to having your own pool when you don't
have to worry about the uh the things
that you know could uh ultimately be in
what do you think people are doing in
there during a game what are you scared
of
peeing has become a little too popular
in pools i just know that there's a
little amount of chlorine no amount of
chlorine in the world that uh can make
up for that all right next one for me
you're leaving sofi stadium on the board
how i mean it's the same it's the same
yeah yeah it's the same i'm not going to
pick it then i'm not going to pick it
because because i want to go i want to
go old school if i'm going to spend a
week in a football stadium i want to go
to lambeau for the week i want to soak
in the echoes and the ghosts and the
history and and just be there right go
out and run around on the grass they're
very very protective of the grass i want
to go out and play football on lambeau
field every day with friends and family
and just kind of hang out and take in
lambeau field and look i mean it's not
like there's a bunch of casinos around
if your point is you got to stay there
the whole week you're staying at lambeau
field the whole week
you're you're right i mean you know hey
i mean you went from vegas to wisconsin
i don't know you're all over the map i
but but you're right i wrote green bay
down too because i i would love to
hang out there's plenty of indoor spots
whether it was warm or cold and then to
run around on a field that you go like
vince lombardi was here bart starr brett
favre baron rogers i mean
it's the most nostalgic stadium in
football so you know because of that i'm
i'm with you in a lot of ways certainly
you know and all right so my next pick
okay well
i think i got to go to jerry's world i
think that's the one that i got to go
with i mean jerry's world has every toy
in the world i mean i don't have to do
anything we could we can play the the
greatest hide and seek game in the
history of the world in that stadium let
alone when i do want to go to sleep i'm
going to the jones family sleep sweet i
know that's going to be plush and be
really well decorated and of course you
know i mean we
hopefully some amenities are open to
where i can get some food and get some
good texas barbecue and do things like
that and then when it's time you know
the day is over to sit back eat some of
that texas barbecue and put on the big
megatron tv and watch a movie that
sounds like a good relaxing vacation to
me so i'm going with uh i can't remember
at t stadium right that's what it is
yeah and that's how the knights tend to
wind down when you're on a family
vacation you find something everybody
gathers around the tv and they've got
the giant four-sided drive-in movie
theater screen hanging over the the
venue you're right you settle into some
some nice reclining chairs in the suite
and you watch a movie on the screen or
or
or
you hook up the ps4 and you play
all night long on that so
i've seen i've seen clips of people
doing that that would be something you
crank the sound up you get the the
vibrations that would be something screw
the movie let's play madden all night
long on the giant video screen so that's
sure your wife would love that your wife
would love that on vacation i'm sure the
place is big enough she can find
something else to go do while we're
playing madden on the giant video board
uh next one for me and you mentioned the
food right if you're gonna spend the
money necessary to rent out an nfl
stadium for a week i assume that is not
an inexpensive proposition you need to
go with some you know
cost
uh sensitive food options so give me
mercedes-benz stadium in atlanta for two
reasons the hot dogs are two dollars and
they're awesome i got a hot dog at the
super bowl this year and it was a lot
more than two dollars and it was not
awesome i got a hot dog last year at
mercedes-benz stadium for the super bowl
it was two bucks and it was incredible
and my son contributed to this
brainstorming for me they got a
chick-fil-a there so you're good to go
for chick-fil-a if you need a
chick-fil-a fix and a lot of people do
it's right there in the stadium so uh
you know you're in atlanta it's a nice
new stadium you can just sit there all
day and open and close the roof that'll
entertain you for half the vacation and
you can get some cheap food and just
kind of hang out in luxury in that
fairly brand new stadium
chris are you there
we lost chris chris says chris was not
dumbfounded again chris is just gone
chris is back and we are back with the
draft of the stadiums that we would want
to rent for a vacation one pick remains
it goes to chris what do you have chris
well as much as i want to pick my tampa
bay buccaneer stadium with the pirate
ship and he could shoot cannons and all
that okay i'm not going to go with that
i'm going with the new england patriots
gillette stadium
patriot place that's why i mean that's
part of their stadium it's connected you
know you got everything at your disposal
mr craft has created a new england world
you can go to the patriots museum
there's lots of restaurants if i got to
get a workout in i could stop at tb12
spot and get that in so to me that is a
win-win situation got my own little
world there and of course can look at
all the nostalgic things and all their
super bowl trophies as i do it so
patriot place will be my last pick
gillette stadium
i have a feeling you'd be on the list of
people to not admit to the tb12
performance do you think
i know
i know i i don't like that you know i i
don't even know what to say anymore i
can't defend myself but i like tom brady
i don't know what else to say i'm just
honest in my opinions and sometimes
they're not popular up there in new
england
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports